i am dr. amit kapoor from the institute
for competitiveness india if you really
look at the meeting and the kind of
interactions we are having it's about
say asian model for transformation of
global economy and if you really look at
the transformation of global economy and
what's going to happen we really need to
learn as as to how really regions within
a country are actually going to be
performing it cannot be a one singular
way of saying that India is a country or
Thailand is a country or Indonesia as a
country that needs to be looked at as a
tool for assessment or a region for
assessment we need to go a little deeper
and try to understand that each of these
countries is forming of regions and how
these regions are doing so we need to
really go and look at a deeper debate as
to how urbanization is happening how
various cities in these regions are
actually growing and how various states
are actually performing and of course
moving down to you the various ideas of
say the crisis that they can world faces
today's are about energy the sustainable
development and unique business models
that need to be created so I think the
world will have to really talk about
energy crisis get those energy crisis
and spray pay where I got managed and
then of course we really need to look at
models which are going to be unique and
inclusive the session that I was just
looking at it was bad of like was on
health care when we really have to
understand that health care tomorrow
will need to be understood and assess
from the idea of outcomes rather than
just talking about things like what's
happening on the ground what's the kind
of diseases so we really need half five
ways in terms of business models which
are going to talk about unique delivery
mechanisms and so on and so forth if we
really talk about an example of India
it's very powerful to see that in India
the basic problem is of accessibility
you're really going to the doctor and
the event of a disease or an onset of a
situation it is a problem you'll really
have to create situations where an
accessibility is solved and resolved so
we are not able to create models of this
nature I think the world is not going to
be happy to place and of course when we
talk about health care as well it's
going to be about prevention it's not
going to be about just taking care of
things that have already have
so I think the agenda is great the
world's going to see a lot of change in
the coming 10 years or 20 years that
your economic challenges would be there
but then this economic challenge itself
provides one of the tremendous
opportunities in the world thank you